In the great Alaska
Range comes a moment
eight months in the making.
Here's where the
opening is going to be
between the two structures.
With just a few precision
cuts, Morgan's one room cabin--
Here will be the first step.
Will open up into
a two story home.
I'm just going to look at
this carefully, because this
is a one shot deal, you know?
I can't do this twice.
I can't mess it up.
Here we go.
I got the first half of
the hole opened up here,
and getting ready to
saw down into the logs
to form the base of the cabin.
If one of those logs has some
weird tension where it wants
to pop out of line
from the other ones,
the whole wall could drop.
And definitely, that
would be catastrophic.
So Here, I just need to attach
some boards to all these logs
so those logs stay put
when I'm sawing them out.
Here we go.
Those are pretty well
locked in together.
I think I've done all
the preparation I can do.
And now I just got to go
ahead and cut the hole.
I'm going to do
this block by block
so that I can kind
of monitor any shift
that might start to happen.
So far so good.
I'll get the rest of
this finished out here.
Whoa.
[bleep]
I think there's a nail in there.
Morgan's breakthrough
grinds to a halt.
I can see it in
there, but it's
not cut all the way through.
Hitting a log screw
with a saw chain
would probably break the chain.
I'll just hit it with a cold
chisel right out of the park.
All right.
I think I just got it there.
Sheared it off.
We need that chainsaw
to cut firewood,
and it's a long way
to the hardware store.
So I'm not going to risk blowing
it on cutting these logs when
we can do it with hand saws.
All right, we're
free on this one.
Take it off.
Look at that nail.
Hopefully, there's
not another one.
Good job.
Look it there.
Oh god.
There's a hole in my house.
I know.
And your house is
getting so much bigger.
That's true.
It's really cool
to see this doorway.
Having this bigger
addition is really going
to improve our quality of life.
But we have to leave the floor
unfinished until the ground
thaws enough that we
can dig out the cellar
area to store our root crops.
A temporary gang
plank bridges that gap
while construction continues.
When we get this screw down
and we can be in business.
OK.
This gangplank is
pretty sturdy here,
and Margaret bucked
up firewood logs
and I'm going to bring
them in and we'll
get the fire going in the stove
It feels great to light the
stove for the first time,
feel the heat coming off of it.
This cookstove is going to be
kind of like the warm heart
of this entire homestead here.
You know, producing
great food and heating
this nice big new
cabin we've got.
First things first.
Took a lot of work to get here.
It definitely took
longer than expected,
but we're building
our safe even more
and it's just very exciting.
Oh, that's cool.
There's still a long
way to go, but at least
we're sitting inside.
Yeah, we got it to
a usable place here,
and it'll be a bit more
work to get finished out.
Kind of don't even want to
think about the whole list.
Just one piece at a time.
- OK.
Bite sized.
Living out here is
challenging, to say the least.
But these kind of
accomplishments really add up.
Cool.
Let's see what else we can do.